hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich habe
heute mit hair day das wirklich moniert
die setup hermann das ist echt behindert
aus also ich habe euch auf twitter
gesagt dass sie mir keine fragen diesmal
stellen sollte wie wir das letzte mal
hier gemacht haben das video verlinkt
ich euch hier übrigens habe ich hier
eine neue lampe in meiner wohnung und
das nicht
jedenfalls sollte den wir bei twitter
keine fragen stellen sondern einfach mal
irgendwelche antworten und ich werde
darauf jetzt irgendwas sagen und ihr
werdet dann antworten und wir fangen an
ich frage euch mal als erstes bild bis
bist du dumm ich habe gerade der
selbstgespräche geführt und dann ist mir
eingefallen eigentlich sind wir beide
sie nicht um die sowieso sagt ja
eigentlich so bescheuert und und ich sag
euch antworten und dann kommt einfach
wir sind beide dort seid ihr bescheuert
wir sind definitiv bescheuert
so nahm ich weiß zwar was sind das
verantworten ich dachte es kommt so was
wie ja keine ahnung was ich erwartet
habe ich habe irgendwie sowas erwartet
wie jo de luca den sinn des lebens
verstehe ich darin dass wir in der
religion und alles und deswegen könnt
ihr vernünftig antworten warum ich weiß
echt nicht
ich könnte die ganze zeit hier so sitzen
komplettes video stellt euch jetzt mal
konkrete fragen und für mein gott meine
haare das ist ja das ist ja nicht mehr
schön ich verletze das beim friseur wir
sehen schon wieder so fucking scheiße
aus was ist ihr am liebsten mit 17 mit
ketten danke danke
endlich mal eine vernünftige antwort ich
meine liebe madame frage ich jetzt mal
ist ist dein pullover blusen pullover
ist nicht plaudert er es weiß glaubt du
solltest zum augenarzt sollte also zum
augenarzt gehen also mein gott diese
kerze vorangegangen ich habe mir so
elektrische kerzen gekauft und die hat
wohl den timer auf 16 49
hier hat man denn hier rein bekommen
mein gott ich habe da jetzt echt 1000
jahre angesetzt diese blöde kerze in
dieses ding rein zu bekommen ich zeige
euch das mal da ach du heiliger gut
vielleicht es mir gerade wieder die
kamera dann das wovor hin
ich weiß es gar nicht halogen- led- die
kerbs verdammte scheiße gerade einfach
wieder umgefallen
ich habe den tollen sticker als apple
das kann man super machen kaufte sachen
im lukas
ich hab grad nichts aus dem lukas shop
an aber ich habe allen paris shirt an
und in lucka shop gibt es auch coole
sachen kauft mein match gegen anna
beschreiben als letzte frage frage ich
euch einfach mal was ist eure maarten st
warum kommt auf einmal warten sagt
kannst wenn du tomaten sagt tomaten sagt
ich sage einfach gar nicht warten
wenn ich mir so eure ganzen antworten
bisher anschaue denke ich mir echt ein
bisschen wie so antwortet ihr so einen
schwachsinn habt ihr überhaupt freunde
ins ferne genau null freunde ich wusste
es ich hab's gewusst
naja ist ja klar ich zeigte man schön
das war nicht schön
mir egal dass ich jetzt video aufnehmen
ich habe 100 pizza pizza pizza das
ekelhafteste auf der welt muss mal kurz
die man auf twitter nokian pizza ist
geil
ok ich lass euch beiden dass man
miteinander eine kombination für einen
pizza das ekelhafteste auf der welt
einfach mal so gefällt mir das ich hätte
jetzt ja echt gern mit pizza aber ich
esse karotte guten appetit die auf jeden
fall so meine freunde die nächste
antwort ist im moment erstens ich habe
gesagt wir sollten wir antworten
schicken keine fragen aber ich nehme es
trotzdem dran das umweltmobil hat er da
extra am anfang die hand hoch genommen
um seine tolle gold uhr zu zeigen ist
die tat er das so richtig dumm er sagte
zugleich auch wenn sich durch die haare
gehen damit man wenn die gold ruhrgebiet
aber du hast glück gehabt egal
willkommen jetzt mal endlich zu seiner
frage hast du eigentlich auch weil sie
richtig bock gehabt ein arschloch zu
decken
nein warum guckst du so dumm
bei solchen einsendungen wisst ihr dann
denke ich mir auch einfach nur ein thema
und an dieser stelle endlich auch schon
wieder das heutige video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen es tut mir leid dass
ich euch mal beleidigendes gefahren hat
und ich denke auch luca du kannst du was
vielleicht noch mal machen dann lass
deine bewerbung da folgten auftritte
aber so war damals
wieso saugen meine nachbarn jetzt